ever feel like your evenings just slip
away you're not alone in this video I'm
sharing eight amazing strategies to
transform your afterwork hours from
wasted time to growth time first we'll
explore into the shutdown ritual a
simple but powerful way to tell your
brain work mode off then I'll show you
how to break your evening into 90-minute
power blocks recovery growth and
connection so you can maximize your
energy and focus but that's just the
start
we'll also explore digital Wellness
hacks like the analog hour one
screen-free hour before bed that'll make
your evenings feel like a sanctuary plus
I'll reveal how future self journaling
can help you wake up feeling inspired
not drained these aren't rigid rules
they're simple practical strategies that
work with your natural energy not
against it ready to reclaim your
evenings and make them the best part of
your day watch the full video to unlock
all eight strategies your future self
will thank you